[Music]
better known as
bic today i'm at mit
sharing with my friend michelle graf
with all the students
sharing my love my poetry and learning
from them too
i was able to have bic in
two of my classes and in both classes
bic had so much to contribute from his
own
biography as a haitian but also as an
artist you made a comment yesterday when
we were discussing in the other class
about
your own uh perception of how
people get treated in haiti depending on
how whether they speak creole
or french lady or most of people speak
spirit
then that that is very difficult for
those people when they go to the public
office because
people are fake it's kind of like the oh
you have your interview voice
you have your phone voice and you have
like the way that you speak with other
people
in ad they would consider you as
educated if you start speaking french
they say if you want to be an
international artist
oh you need to sing in english you need
to speak in french but not in korean
[Music]
it is a distance they put a gay dayport
to make you feel like you're inferior
inferior according to a language and
what you're saying
is that well no our language our culture
is an asset is wealth and if you proud
of that
if you valorize that then you can also
valorize your country and you can
share something precious that's it with
the entire world
we're here right now in the uh cafe
creole in everett
karaoke all going on tonight uh this is
something that's
sponsored by mit and art and mit
so we're excited to have a great night
tonight with the ic
also is in the house so it's going to be
a very fun check check check
there's this potential to have the ic
performing everett at this
restaurant that's very well frequented
by haitians and in a way
that will also allow mit to reach out to
the community and vice versa
boston has the third largest asian
community
and yet you have kids right here in
cambridge
who don't know where mit is so i think
it tells us something about
this divide between places like mit and
the electric community yeah and i think
having someone like bic
here can help
thank you very much today
in the universities they have my lyrics
in creole
and they are happy to work over them
even if i die tomorrow
my lyrics will be your life this is very
important
to me i've been meeting students from
mit
americans africans
asians caribbean caribbean island a lot
for example let me give you some example
i learned
poetry has no language you remember the
the student who showed me
a poetry with images there was no
sentences almost i can explain that a
little bit if you'd like
um i'm trying to see if i can figure it
out but i'm sure i will need your help
don't let me know then i realize
that is an expression she's trying to
say something
it's not just about language you see
it's not just about language it's about
something you as a creator have inside
and what you share
what they are saying in eddie is like
there's a nation going
invited by mit they would want me to
talk about this experience how was it
how did you receive you i was like i was
home
people took me for who i am a person not
the color of my skin
not which country i'm from they really
saw me as human being
and that helped me to better share with
them you see everyone was like a family
everyone is a brother hey when are you
coming back
are you going to sing that song for me
no i want to listen to that song that is
their song not mine anymore
when you are a musician you speak a
language
that the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my